five-year-old child is dead police say
she is the victim of a murder i'm brian
loftis i'm david charns in for denise
tonight right now police are calling the
child's mother the suspect
vanessa murphy has been working to find
out more she's here with what she found
out vanessa
sources tell me two little girls were
found locked inside a hot bedroom with
no air conditioning a five-year-old girl
did not survive her
two-year-old sister was rescued and
taken by child
protective services this evening their
mother is in jail
metro police say the call came in after
seven monday evening
here's a look at the scene today this is
a home just off of maryland parkway
between
cactus and pyle it's the silverado ranch
area
23-year-old kamehameha darshay taylor
was arrested
and she faces a murder charge along with
two counts of
felony child abuse sources tell me she
was outside
throwing rocks at cars and acting
erratically
and then police found the two children
metro's abuse and neglect team is
investigating and the cause of death for
the five-year-old girl
is still under investigation a hearing
is scheduled for taylor on thursday
morning
it appears she'll remain in custody at
the clark county detention center
so again metro police say they are
investigating the child's death
a five-year-old girl is now dead and
sources are telling me she was found in
a
hot room with no air conditioning ted
florento tells me the high
in that neighborhood yesterday was 107.
back to you but